on écoute l'objectif de cette visite est
évidemment de faire un point d'étape sur
la situation politique
ma position est toujours la même c'est
celle de l'exigence sans ingérence j'ai
vu qu'un processus s'était enclenchée
ces dernières heures qui a permis de
faire émerger une figure en tant que
premier ministre il ne m'appartient
aucunement ni de l'approuver ni de
l'adouber c'est la souveraineté
libanaise qui est ici en jeu alors c'est
la souveraineté des lyonnaises qui est
ici en jeu comment on peut être comme
dirait manal macro exigeant sans faire
de l'ingérence dans le cadre du liban et
des libanais ils sont assez habituelles
à gérance et à la gérance manu militari
si j'ose dire un l'ingérence des syriens
au liban
ça a duré 20 depuis le début des gars de
toute façon puisque la syrie n'a jamais
l'existence du liban faut rappeler que à
l'époque de l'empiré ottoman le liban
était dépendant des villas y est c'est à
dire des grandes préfecture sous empire
ottoman qui était celle de damas et
celle d'annette donc ça n'existait pas
en tant que tel en tant que structure si
vous voulez administratif le liban avec
celle de la villa y est de beyrouth et
celle de tripoli c'est la fin du 19e
bon donc prendre pour très long pendant
très longtemps c'était un ensemble qui
était la syrie donc pour les syriens le
liban n'avait aucune raison d'exister
bien donc c'est vraiment jaillir un
rapport de force politique
le corner dans de la géopolitique entre
évidemment un empire ottoman qui est
complètement affaibli et on va dire
dépecer un rapport de force entre la
grande bretagne et la france sur le
proche orient qui va faire que on va
créer le grand liban avec une alliance
que font les français à ce moment là qui
est l'alliance avec les chrétiens du
liban avec les maronites
incontestablement bon donc on crée ce
grand liban qui n'a donc jamais été
véritablement accepté dans le sol par
les scieries jeu de deuxième ingérence
parce que c'est pas fini
ingérence extrêmement importante celle
d'israël sur le sud liban puisqu'on a eu
d'occupation d'israël
dans le sud liban pendant longtemps très
longtemps des inquiétudes exactement
donc là on a une ingérence aussi qui est
important on a eu une ingérence on va
dire aussi parlent par le biais des
états unis qui sont intervenus fortement
au liban dont étudiants et le liban la
gérance c'est allé un peu vite en
besogne que les liens de la france est
avec le liban soit des liens
particulière d'abord on a une chasse
porat libanaise en france qui est
importante qu'on ne peut pas nier faut
quand même rappeler qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de libanais hors du liban deux à
trois fois plus qu'il n'y en a au liban
c'est un phénomène très important très
intéressant qu'elles soient dans
l'amérique latine qu'elle soit en
afrique ou qu'elle soit à paris ou à
londres bon donc c'est quelque chose qui
est tout à fait est tout à fait
important
on a aussi une relation si vous voulez
même dans un pays aussi sécularisée que
le nôtre est devenu aussi peu religieux
que le nôtre une relation avec les
chrétiens du liban qui forte qui est
importante et qu'on ne peut pas nier
vous avez toute une éducation qui se
fait par les écoles confessionnelles qui
sont des écoles religieuses la grande
université saint joseph par exemple de
jésuites
donc on a ciblé une présence et un rôle
le nombre de libanais qui parle un
français parfait et c'est quand même à
chaque fois tout à fait surprenant donc
il est assez normal enfin moi j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt bien
devant cette émotion qu'a représenté ses
textes
7 cette explosion par négligence par
d'autres raisons que je ne connais pas
qu'il y ait la présence du dieu du
précédent alors c'est pas avec ses
petits bras qui varient question on est
bien d'accord mais moi je pense que pour
le peuple libanais ou pour une grand
partie du peuple libanais on va pas dire
tout ce qui est pour une grande
je pense que c'était tout à fait
important qui dit yann alexis c'est la
question c'est est-ce que
oui la question qu'on veut sur twitter
est ce que ça peut être utile et est-ce
que qu'est ce que ça peut jouer alors un
évidemment c'est une ingérence une
exigence sans ingérence c'est un
sophisme
c'est une ingérence ingérence qui
s'appuie sur tout l'arrière plan
historique qui vient d'être parfaitement
décrit qui remontent jusqu'à saint louis
va les lier au laos en aliment bon
ingérence qui est assez bien accepté
le premier déplacement de macrohori ball
au fond qu'est-ce qui fait il va prendre
le parti de de la population contre les
dirigeants avec ça c'est du billard
s'efface et donc les gens disent il va
dire vous les corrompus les incapables
changer vos méthodes ou dégager la place
parce que maintenant vous êtes en train
de mettre ce pig et si on va vous aider
on va vous apporter de l'aide voilà
allez on va c'est pas le libanais qui
entend sable il aimerait bien y croire
et franchement je pense pas qu'on puisse
reprocher à mieux maintenant d'essayer
après tout si ça pouvait marcher ça
serait formidable
bon deuxième question et c'est la fin de
vie dont vous posez c'est est-ce que ça
peut marcher
moi je suis évidemment un expert de la
question mais on voit qu'on voit le
noeud de difficultés de contradictions
d'hostilité de communauté qui à la fois
se tiennent ce maïs combattent de de
lien d'argent 202 puisse d'intervention
étrangère dire tous à dire que parce que
la france va arriver et 10 rebonds pop
up off aller maintenant je sécurisée
aujourd'hui en trois coups de cuillère à
pot ou tel oss 117
je suis un tout petit peu sceptique bon
il a obtenu deux ponts change de premier
ministre il a obtenu que les aides
soient contrôlés et à yves à ceux qui en
ont besoin et qu'on se les met dans la
poche ce qui n'est pas rien il a obtenu
que le président aoun face des très
belles déclarations de bodinat le site
et de laïcité après tout ces voix là bon
après la réalité libanaise va reprendre
le dessus la réalité vous jugez
politique va reprendre le dessus
l'arrêté ddd des conflits armés à
l'intérêt même du liban va rependre
dessus une des questions
c'était ce qu'il faut discuter avec le
hezbollah avait quand même quelque chose
c'est que ça fait déjà un moment qu'on a
des boues
de la population libanaise qui sont
importants c'est pas le dernier qu'a eu
dans 2019 mais il y en avait déjà eu
auparavant où on a une population plutôt
jeune qui dit mais nous on veut sortir
de ça on veut plus aller se marier à
chypre pour se marier civilement et pas
être obligée d'épouser qui musulmanes
chrétiennes etc
c'est un mouvement qui n'est pas du tout
à négliger qu'important qui avait tenu
quand même dans la durée longtemps le
problème c'est qu'il ne sort pas de ces
mouvements là ni à celui qui a eu lieu
il ya déjà une petite dizaine d'années
ou celui qui a eu lieu récemment ne sort
pas de figure qui soit capable de
fédérer et d'organiser tout ça ça je
peux te fait de grave et que sortir de
ce noeud libanais il ya tellement
d'intérêts il ya tellement d'enjeux
à ceci près qu'on est quand même dans
une situation financière pour le liban
absolument catastrophique et que là
alors ils feront peut-être juste le
colmatage pour opter dans raison qui est
la question à l'autre question c'est
celle que vous sauviez l'instant c'est
justement les discussions avec le
hezbollah 27 personnalités demandent
dans le figaro justement que le
hezbollah soit considérée comme la par
la france comme organisation terroriste
votre point de vue sur la question sur
le principe on peut dire très bien la
seule chose c'est que le hezbollah est
un état dans l'état aujourd'hui au liban
que c'est quand même l'armé du hezbollah
qui a défait l'armée israélienne quand
en 2006 ce qui n'est quand même pas rien
quand on sait comment fonctionne l'armée
israélienne donc c'est bien gentil sûr
mais dans la neutralisation qui dit
actuellement justement on dénonce la
mainmise du hezbollah derrière des
dénonciation de la corruption des ans il
a même dit de baseball est ce qu'il ya
une opportunité on peut pas accuser le
hezbollah d'être le seul responsable de
la corruption
ça c'est tellement simple bon c'est à
dire que tout le monde est mouillé ce
nietzsche it s beaulac et d'une partie
du schisme et maronites tout autant donc
le toute façon dans le marigot
on les trouve tous donc on va pas parler
simplement de le hezbollah a des moyens
c'est évident c'est pas des imbéciles
non plus il contrôle très bien un
territoire
il a ri
va dire à aider une population qui est
complètement abandonné par les
structures de l'état
l'armée libanaise n'a jamais désarmé
l'armée du hezbollah alors c'est bien
gentil de dire on doit pas parler avec
eux mais vous savez on voulait pas
parler avec le fln en algérie non plus
on veut jamais parlé avec les
terroristes
il arrive bien un moment où on est bien
obligé de prendre le rapport de force et
discuter avec ses amis
c'est facile sur ses terres dépression
mais encore faut-il quand on discute
avec ses ennemis avoir suffisamment
d'arguments et de moyens de pression
pour pas se faire avoir dans la
discussion
c'est sale c'est vous parlez bien sûr
qu'avant à la fin des fins il faut
parler en position de force et là on
raconte le dialogue tout puisque donc
emmanuel macron alors que les états unis
l'allemagne et normandes pique quand tu
te considérais qu'il faut absolument pas
parler au hezbollah
macron a vu le responsable du hezbollah
dans un cadre collectif et puis là peut
discuter avec lui de façon à part et lui
dit d'après ce que ce que georges
malbrunot qui était sur place nous
raconte je veux travaillent avec vous
pour changer le liban prouver vous êtes
libanais tout le monde sait que vous
avez un agenda iranien on connaît votre
histoire
on sait votre identité mais vous êtes
libanais wind on voulait des libanais
oui non vous parlez du pape libanais
oui/non donc rentré à la maison quitter
la syrie le yémen et fait le boulot ici
pour construire un état et que ce nouvel
état bénéficier vos familles il a raison
c'est formidable mais comment dire
écoute très gentiment mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait changer les gens
donc il faut avoir mais il ya sûrement
d'autres paramètres dans ces discussions
très cher mais la boue pour discute
enfin on discute pas il ya un os ou pas
exact sauf avec une très longue cuillère
il faut avoir je pense surtout un gros
bâton pour du parle parle avec le dire
parce que dira l'iran et le fond c'est
dire environ
dans ces conditions là il ya aussi une
partie de billard c'est l'iran c'est
l'enjeu est effectivement de l'accord
sur le nucléaire qui est extrêmement
important et donc des sanctions
donc l'enjeu c'est aussi les élections
américaines avec trump qu'est ce qui se
passe si c'est bayonne qui est
élu est-ce qu'on revient sur cet accord
là auquel cas le rapport et changera ou
est-ce que c'est rome qui est réélu au
quel cas rien ne change c'est un peu
passive ou les raisonner sur le liban
exclusivement dans les frontières
libanaises sur une situation
exclusivement les manèges si on raisonne
comme ça on comprendra pas le jeu qui
peut se faire entre israël iran etats
unis et j'irai pas l'europe puisqu'elle
n'existe pas en tant que puissances
internationales
mais j'allais dire macron essaye moderne
application c'est que l'europe n'existe
pas en paix tant de puissance
intéressant même si on connaît pas trop
de ces questions là il à la complexité
de lorient et du proche orient
c est ce qu a au moins il n'y a pas un
signe dans cette visite d' emmanuel
macron qui va deux fois en un mois
c'est quand même le maintien d'une
certaine influence française dans cette
dans cette région a incontestablement
regarder quand le drian y est allé en
disant on mais on met de l'argent pour
que les écoles les jeux les lycées
puisse continuer et qu'on puisse
continuer à avoir un enseignement
français quand il va fait ça c'est bien
évidemment pour maintenir une présence
française est gardée effectivement une
culture française qu'on le voit dans les
journaux on le voit moi j'ai des
collègues universitaires libanais qui
parle un français impeccable et bien
évidemment des qui viennent dans nos
colloques etc
bien sûr que c'est ça et ici je dirais
parfaitement légitime
heureusement oui la france a encore ce
lien avec le liban est une si elle a un
endroit dans le monde dans cette zone de
houla elle existe encore un peu c'est
libre la question c'est est-ce qu'elle
existe suffisamment et vraiment je pense
pas qu'on puisse faire le reproche avait
bien macron d'essayer d'améliorer les
choses c'est toujours bien d'essayer
mais ce qu'elle existe suffisamment pour
faire évoluer les choses dans le bon
sens
bon maintenant si on ne sait pas on est
soi pas y arriver là sur le fond la
situation interne au liban est beaucoup
trop complexe pour espérer un changement
c'est ce que vous me baby nommé mais
vous
vous voyez dans cette visite de lehman
macron et bien un acte symbolique et
patrick se demande si macron pactise pas
avec le hezbollah pour se voir décerner
un prix nobel de la paix on en est pas
encore là
à vous entendre la question qu'on vous
posez c'est est pensez vous que l'action
des manuels macron au liban est utile
vous utile et partager cet endroit
répondre 47% nous répondent oui 53% à
répondre non preuve que les choses sont
pas complètement tranché sur sur la
question pour m'être bien des choses en
contexte le récit d'un siècle de
relations entre la france et le liban
c'est signé le renault gérard il ya cent
ans la france créé l'état du grand liban
c'est le titre de cet article est tout
le dossier à retrouver sur le site du
figaro merci beaucoup pour cette
première formule et on se retrouve
demain même heure même endroit et vous
retrouver guillaume roquette
[Musique]
et